il y a une goutte de pluie sur le cadre
eh bien c'est parti
ok ok soutenons
tout de suite
étranger étranger
ok
tu vois ce que je dis je pensais que tu
disais riposter je sais que ça va te
dire que tu violes ta propre règle
je suppose que c'est  tu as raison cependant
c'est le problème avec ça
si nous allons avoir de la pluie
protégez la caméra bébé
[ __ ]
tu y vas
oh trop brumeux ouais on va juste le faire
ils ne sauront jamais
ce qu'ils font dans
la zone militaire ouais  et ouais
probablement peur que la plage
prenne feu du
sable d'accord le prochain se transforme en verre
ouais ça a l'air plutôt mauvais ouais ça a l'air
vraiment bien d'accord ouais
par ici je pense euh est-ce que je vois
quelque chose peut-être par le nez là
ouais c'est comme
non  c'est tout droit d'accord
pause s'il vous plaît il
y en a probablement plus en bas à
gauche ici quelque part
peut-être d'accord
beaucoup de maisons hors de cela je ne peux pas cibler ouais
ouais faisons une rotation autour d'elle et
puis euh faisons-en une vers cette
belle lumière dans le  lac et nous aimerons juste
regarder par-dessus bonjour pouvons-nous aller ici
Ben nous pouvons probablement
être géniaux à faire comme une sorte de
tir en avant ouais dessus ouais je veux dire de
ne pas rouler là-bas
j'ai plus à l'extérieur tu sais qu'il y a
ça
oh
il y a quelque chose de l'autre côté de
cette eau ne restez pas ici des gouttes d'eau fraîche
sur la fenêtre de l'aéroport d'accord d'accord
Voyons euh voyons si nous ne pouvons pas passer par-dessus
celui-là euh
wow attends
je suis désolé mec reprenons-le un
un peu plus loin il y a un mois comme faire un
parcours inverse comme celui-ci prendre au-dessus
de l'eau
si intéressant à la recherche ouais
étranger
merci
ouais
c'est possible
étranger allez-y
on le fait sans la pluie ouais j'espère
hé maintenant on va à gauche  de
cette colline ouais
ouaistout de
suite
oh mon Dieu il y a comme cinq maisons
oh ouais
wow regarde ça ouais
je ne sais pas combien de temps ça va vraiment
rester je veux dire je ne sais pas si on
peut atterrir ou pas mais non on peut  n'atterris pas
ici
es-tu sûr
wow ça va juste tu vois tout
ça
ouais peut-être euh les gens traversent leurs
maisons ouais le
week-end
et si nous euh si nous faisons des trucs plus longs,
continuez alors aussi longtemps que
ces maisons  continuez
nous faisons un peu plus de temps wow regardez ce qui se passe
ces rangées de terre cuite elles fondent
si nous faisons des trucs plus longs cela aidera à
minimiser la situation de l'eau d'accord
wow c'est incroyable d'
accord
en fait nous allons traîner ici et
faire beaucoup de coups  pour à propos de ça oh il y
a une il y a une maison juste à deux
heures où il y a comme 10 personnes dans
le champ
à une heure oh ouais
en fait juste
ici d'accord
wow c'est une déception
pour Archway qui est toujours debout ouais
incroyable
regarde il y a un gars qui pellette  ouais
euh Ben voyez-vous le gars montrer si vous
pouvez voir les démangeaisons vous commencez en quelque sorte à
avancer un peu bon
chef
ici
wow
ouais continuez aussi je peux comprendre que je suis
aligné sur cet arbre que l'eucalyptus est
sur le chemin  là tu vas là
tu vas ouais
c'est bien ouais
étranger
déplaçons-nous devant pour
que cette arche soit en quelque sorte cadrée d'accord
je pense qu'ils nous en veulent
nous allons rester ici pendant quelques
minutes
ouais comme un animal nous '  les visualiser
c'est super avec ce front ouais
ouais c'est très bien
la façon dont ils essaient de passer là-bas il
doit y avoir quelque chose là-dessous à
la recherche de leur cachette Ouais
cent mille dollars qui ont enterré
payer pour de l'argent
étranger
ouais je pense que la pluie a  arrêté et
la lumière est plutôt bonne ça va
passer par ici
euh peut-être qu'on devrait faire notre approche d'accord oh eh bien ouais
c'est génial et tu vois
comme toutes les autres maisons partout
wow
hé
il y a du genre vraiment sympa de voir le coureur de dieu
descendre  ouais
ouais ouais
ta main te fait mal non c'est juste fatigué
nous allons juste devenir si drôles après un
moment
zoomer puis dézoomer à nouveau
tenir l'
étranger
oui il
y a des adolescents que tu peux
faire n'importe quoi
c'est incroyable qu'il y ait un
espace paysager  derrière c'est juste parfaitement
vert encore ouais
on va faire un coup d'approche après que
la lumière soit plutôt sympa bien
merci
ça 26 26 d'accord
juste en dessous de moi il y a comme une autre
maison que nous allons avoir et les essieux sont
tous euh rose
ouais c'est le  toit en terre cuite c'est
comme ça je pense que tu connais ces
rangées de tuiles ils je pense qu'ils ont juste
tourné la poudre je vois d'accord tu peux
arrêter d'accord les gens qui passent
wow
dis moi quand tu commences ton tour
ça commence maintenant
d'accord
les gens partout
ouais
mais  nous en avons aussi deux là-bas si vous
voulez leur dire que
je peux tourner un peu plus à droite d'accord il y en a
deux d'affilée là-bas oh
ouais
c'est que c'est
wow c'était une belle maison à une époque oh
ouais
c'est beaucoup
souais
mon plaisir d'accord d'accord
ouais
ça va juste aller dans ce truc je suppose que
c'est drôle en fait parce que toutes les
collines
continuent en fait sur les collines parce que
c'est qu'elles sont toutes euh eh
bien ça ne vaut pas vraiment la peine d'aller dans
le lac mais ça dit
oui allons-y  au lac comme
ça
mais ouais c'est euh merci
ça a l'air bien ouais
juste pas trop lent
c'est un peu comme ça commencez à marcher
ouais plus en ligne avec la lumière dans le
laser
vous ne pouvez presque pas voir ces maisons d'oiseaux
d'accord
ouais
laissons ça ouais je pense que l'
eau s'écoule de ces
garçons
juste pour faire une sorte de rotation mais roulez
ouais d'accord
Bill plus lent
et ensuite nous ferons ce tir inversé que
nous aimons que vous aimiez avant ouais
vous diriez que nous allumons  ouais
tout le monde a apprécié
bonjour ils
suivent toute la ligne de crête
je regarde celle qui est en bas euh
vers l'avant là oh d'accord
étranger
nous avions aussi des panneaux solaires
oh
ouais euh
on
fait juste la même ligne alors on l'a fait euh
avant  ouais ça marche jusqu'à présent c'est à peu près
ça
sur la droite
il l'a laissé j'en
vois un sur la droite
maintenant c'est parti je pense que ça a explosé
vraiment incroyable que certaines maisons je sais que
c'est bizarre ça les sélectionne juste c'est
un appel proche  sur ces bons
contacts, allez
peut-être tout droit du
bord et c'est
une bonne idée
Power Tower November se termine sur l'ILS
juste euh presque un décent wow
c'est fou merci
dites-lui que nos tours descendent
allons tout droit d'accord d'accord
ouais tous  trois minutes d'accord
une fois de plus
devons-nous monter un peu jusqu'à ce que
nous ayons la jambe et la lumière dessus d'accord
ouais pour que nous puissions nous aligner à nouveau
nous ramener un peu un
peu ouais d'accord
grimper
un  un peu plus lent qui coule vite
à un moment donné vous voulez que j'arrête ou
ouais mais pas encore d'accord
déprimant d'accord
comme maintenant ouais
comme ça ouais d'accord la paix merci merci
oui madame
je vais juste finir cette cassette avec ce
plan ouais
ouais je  comprend
ouais c'est vrai
je connais tous tes secrets maintenant
fais attention tu perds l'Horizon oui